continúa la información aquí entre el 24
y hablamos de economía estamos para eso
con danielle hablando que nos va a
contar lo más importante de hoy daniela
bienvenida nuevamente venezuela puso en
circulación un nuevo billete cuéntenos
hola liliana pues este país está
presionado por una hiperinflación
estimada en más de dos mil seiscientos
por ciento únicamente en el mes de enero
de este año eso es es necesario que el
banco central emita billetes de mayor
denominación hasta el momento era el de
50 mil bolívares pero muchos de quienes
protagonizan las largas filas en los
bancos de caracas ya comenzaron a
recibir los nuevos ejemplares de 200 mil
y 500 mil bolívares también el banco
central emitió un billete de un millón
de bolívares este último con un valor de
apenas 50 centavos de dólar al tipo de
cambio actual y eso alcanza para comprar
liliana para que se haga una idea dos
boletos de ida y vuelta en el transporte
público bueno muy fuerte este tema ni el
en reinounido los conductores de uber ya
son considerados empleados formales a
partir de este miércoles los más de 70
mil conductores
británicos gozarán de ciertos beneficios
como por ejemplo un salario vacaciones
pagas y cotización a pensiones así lo
ordenó la corte suprema- en un caso que
iniciaron en 2016 dos ex conductores de
uber que ya tiene sentencia a su favor a
pesar de la apelación de la compañía
estos trabajadores ahora recibirán por
lo menos el salario mínimo británico que
es de unos 12 dólares la hora para
mayores de 25 años la compañía respondió
que esto no les conviene porque hoy
ganan más de 17 dólares por hora y ahora
no tendrán la flexibilidad para decidir
cuándo y dónde trabajar y en españa
están pensando en hacer lo mismo con los
repartidores de domicilios de comida
pero yo se quejan de no poder escoger si
quieren ser trabajadores o
independientes bueno daniela y hubo
manifestaciones violentas en líbano por
la devaluación de la moneda así eso es
como lo hacen periódicamente desde que
inició la crisis a finales del 2019 los
manifestantes ahora bloquearon algunas
de las principales carreteras del país
esta vez porque su moneda alcanzó
nuevamente el mínimo histórico frente al
dólar en el mercado ilegal
para comprenderlo pues hay que decir que
para comprar un dólar se necesitan
15.000 libras libanesas hace dos semanas
eran nueve mil novecientos eso significa
que la moneda se ha desvalorizado en un
50% y en menos de dos años ha perdido un
90 por ciento de su valor como lo vamos
a observar en el siguiente gráfico una
de las mejores maneras de medir lo es en
términos de salario mínimo en este país
es de 675 mil libras al mes que es el
salario mínimo en octubre de 2019
alcanzaban para 450 dólares hace dos
semanas eran 67 dólares y ahora esto cae
a la dramática cifra de 45 dólares
liliana bueno daniela y también quienes
trabajan detrás de escenas de los
premios oscar enfrentar una dura
temporada este año si se estima que una
sola temporada normal de entrega de
premios oscar inyecta a la economía de
los ángeles alrededor de 130 millones de
dólares
pero este año se enfrentan a una
ceremonia muy distinta y virtual además
que se celebra el próximo 25 de abril y
quiénes están detrás de escena están
luchando para llegar a fin de mes como
este fabricante de alfombras rojas que
veremos este material no sólo es un
accesorio en el mundo del espectáculo
sino también un símbolo icónico de
hollywood
don slip más durante la temporada de
premios no duermo mucho trabajo sin
parar trabajamos sin descanso a las 24
horas del día con eventos consecutivos
el récord es de 15 eventos 15 fiestas en
un solo día
sting
hemos perdido alrededor del 80% de
nuestros eventos en esta temporada es
muy difícil no sé cómo explicarlo
aloha to explain it y como él también
quedaron sin trabajo los floristas los
cocineros fotógrafos y hasta conductores
de limusinas quien se gana la vida en
fiestas y estrenos de películas que
tienen un lugar en el marco de estos
eventos muy triste daniela cuéntanos
entonces cómo están para hoy los
indicadores de la jornada wall street
cerró mixto el mercado está muy
expectante por la reunión de la reserva
federal que comenzó este martes las
bolsas europeas también pendientes de la
fed cerraron positivas y en américa
latina la bolsa de buenos aires rompió
una buena racha positiva y perdió en la
jornada de hoy y terminamos con la cifra
al día
1600 en los 260 mil empleos formales que
generó brasil en enero de este año el
mejor resultado para este mes desde el
inicio de la serie gracias danger ayer
gracias continúen con más entradas 24
punto com
[Música]